if you had to go on a date would you
rather have a date with
young chandler or young joey courtney
cox is putting her 17 year old daughter
coco to the ultimate test when it comes
to a game of who knows best
i'm just open for everything on
wednesday the actress posted a video on
instagram of she and her daughter
quizzing each other
and during a bonus round we learned the
answer to this
interesting friends related question if
you had to go on a date
would you rather have a date with young
chandler or young joey
i'm gonna say young joey
correct well apparently i know coco more
than she knows me
i feel like that's not true but whatever
and we might have to agree with coco
considering the last answer was pretty
obvious given chandler bing
played by matthew perry was courtney's
tv boyfriend
for a majority of friends run we're too
good
we owe it to sex
well if we owe it
oh my courtney posted the video to
promote the season finale of her show
nine months with courtney cox on
facebook watch where families share
their unfiltered experiences with
pregnancy
these families are willing to go to
great lengths for the chance to become
parents oh my god
it won't always be easy losing my job
and being pregnant what am i gonna do
but the desire to bring new life into
the world keeps them going
in 2019 courtney explained to e.t why
this show means so much to her
just the story of life before birth is
so interesting and i
love human stories i just love things
that are real
and i think this particular shows people
can
relate to every part of it or any part
of it and i think the stories are
important to tell just because you
you want to know that you're not alone
and it gives people hope it's something
that people can
interact with they can write into
facebook and write to each other and
share their experiences and so it's it's
kind of
it brings people together i think the
subject matter is something i've always
been attracted to and the way it's done
is so different the friend star
also opened up about her own motherhood
journey and how it's affected her
because most celebrities really do keep
their stuff private you know and here
you're putting it out on sort of
no one ever taught me that lesson i
didn't know you're supposed to be
private i just don't think like that i
i'm not i just
kind of say what's happening in my life
yes probably not always served me well
but that's just who i am so
if i can share any light or give wisdom
to somebody yeah or hope
that of course i would share anything i
can and um
i think that's important you know how
thankful are you that
you are a mom and you get to look
through this with a mother's eyes
um and that your journey which was a
struggle
ended up in coco i'm extremely
thankful i'm i feel very blessed to have
coco and
that wasn't easy for sure but the hard
part is that we have a time limit
and it's it's kind of that's the part
that seems
unfair but other than that i love
watching and experiencing
all these different couples and single
people and all just
everybody that we're following i just i
get to live vicariously through them
or not some of it's really rough another
thing courtney is celebrating
her first emmy nomination for the
friends reunion special on hbo
which she helped executive produce
rachel wrote ross
a letter and demanded he read it before
they got back together
how many pages was that letter 18 pages
18 pages
front and back front and back is correct
and in may she dished to et on what it
was like returning to the set
after all these years it was the most
emotion i i
i had slept so well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all
just feeling good the first question
like how do you feel i was like
and then started crying and then i
walked on the set and i had no idea
that seeing everything look exactly the
same and these incredible friends that
even though i see
these two a lot i i still was just like
jenna are you crying as much as me she's
like yeah
it was just the most emotional thing and
then today she can't stop crying
[Music]